[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Jean-Philippe Tanguy bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous cette députée
rassemblement national de la somme on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représentée par Christelle
Bertrand du groupe La Dépêche bonjour
Christelle bonjour Oriane bonjour on a
beaucoup de sujets à voir avec vous et
évidemment ce qui va se passer au
Parlement dans les prochains jours mais
d'abord un mot sur l'Ukraine puisque
sans grande surprise les référendum
d'annexion par Moscou de quatre régions
ukrainiennes prurus ont été approuvés à
quasiment 100%, Catherine Colonna la
ministre étrangère pardon parle d'une
mascarade est-ce que vous vous
reconnaissez ce résultat non bien sûr
que non c'est évidemment une mascarade
on ne peut pas organiser des référendums
en territoire non seulement en guerre
mais annexé militairement dans des
conditions que tout le monde a pu
constater qui n'ont ni que ni tête donc
c'est une nouvelle étape dans le
comportement à la fois incompréhensible
condamnable et tragique de la Russie
dans cette guerre
vous savez la ligne du rassemblement
national mais dans tous les conflits qui
se tiennent depuis l'Irak c'est le droit
international nous nous demandons
toujours par exemple dans les crimes de
guerre qui peuvent être soupçonnés en
Ukraine on demande des enquêtes
internationales menées par l'ONU le
droit international c'est la seule
solution pour sortir de ce conflit parce
que le but c'est aussi de rétablir au
moins cesser le feu de parvenir à la
paix et c'est seulement le droit
international qui permettra de sortir de
ce conflit au plus vite c'est droit
international mais comment on fait pour
aujourd'hui pour stopper l'avancée de la
Russie qui qui se poursuit
l'Ukraine au combat il faut le dire avec
une armée nationale courageuse sur ce
front donc le front après avoir été
stabilisé a été enfoncé du côté russe
c'est peut-être l'occasion justement
critiquer les sanctions mais qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire d'autre bah vous savez
justement à partir du moment où le front
russe a été enfoncé par les Ukrainiens
c'est peut-être l'occasion de relancer
les négociations de paix qui avait pu se
tenir en Turquie ou en tout cas avec les
Turcs et puis c'est en Turquie parce que
moi ce qui nous inquiète depuis quelques
mois c'est aussi le le l'abandon
visiblement de toute discussion de paix
alors une guerre l'urgence c'est d'en
sortir chaque jour qui fait c'est des
victimes des victimes innocentes des
victimes militaires et donc il faut
absolument profiter de l'affaiblissement
visiblement militaire de la Russie pour
relancer des négociations de paix alors
on va parler du travail au Parlement il
y a beaucoup de choses à dire on
commence par le budget oui qui est le
gros dossier actuellement vous avez été
très virulent lundi en commission des
finances à sa Bruno Le Maire première
question sur la forme est-ce que cela
traduit un changement qui va s'appliquer
dans l'hémicycle on sait que pendant
tout le mois de juillet vous avez été
relativement calme vous avez été
soucieux de d'acquérir une certaine
respectabilité est-ce que finalement
votre temps va changer aujourd'hui là je
parle du groupe rassemblement national
alors
le pdfr en juillet et le deuxième
indicatif en juillet il me semble alors
je on est toujours mauvais juste de
soi-même que j'ai été effectivement
ferme mais j'ai donné des arguments
précis ce que je critique dans ce budget
c'est pas critique pour la critique
c'est que dans les grands économique qui
ont été faits Monsieur le Maire est le
monsieur Macron derrière ne lutte pas
contre les ce que j'ai appelé les
piliers de l'inflation c'est à dire pour
nous l'inflation n'est pas ne tombe pas
du ciel elle est liée à sa zone de
comportement spéculatif notamment sur le
marché de l'électricité cette phase de
règles que Marine Le Pen dénonce depuis
plus d'un an entre l'indexation du près
de l'électricité pardon sur le gaz moi
j'ai fait un calcul si on sortait de
cette règle le prix de machrey pour la
France est divisé par 5 sortir des
règles donc on les français si vous
voulez n'ont pas à payer les marges des
marques de spéculatif des des des
surprofis qui n'ont pas lieu d'être donc
c'est pour ça qu'on est virulent c'est
qu'à un moment on a accepté de laisser
au gouvernement l'occasion de débattre
de prendre en compte un certain nombre
d'arguments de l'opposition mais il faut
reconnaître que sur le texte de juillet
comme sur le texte nous est présenté
aujourd'hui en fait c'est l'application
pure est parfait du programme d'Emmanuel
Macron sans tenir compte du tout du
résultat des élections législatives
les élections législatives à gagner un
pouvoir qu'il pouvoir exécutif
présidentiel mais il a perdu la majorité
à la Chambre et qui devrait faire mais
il a perdu la majoritaire absolue mais
c'est quand même lui qui a le plus grand
nombre de sièges en tout cas ça
majorités vous n'avez pas le pouvoir
législatif donc le peuple français a
décidé qu'il fallait discuter qu'il
fallait faire des compromis il n'en fait
pas pour le moment je passe aussi enfin
j'étais très franc avec Gabriel Attal
dit on était en syndrome de Stockholm
volontaire c'est-à-dire qu'on venait
pour avoir les informations qu'on
pouvait avoir mais on savait très bien
que c'était une manipulation médiatique
vous savez moi j'ai été invité au
dialogue de Bercy en tant que
représentant du RN à la coalition des
Finances à travers le Parisien le
journal qui m'a appelé un dimanche en me
disant ah bah ce que vous vous allez
venir au dialogue de Bercy donc c'était
tellement une opération de com que les
députés ont été invités par les
journalistes avant d'être invité par le
ministre de vos propositions n'a été
prises en compte
à essayer de me tacler en commission en
disant que c'était tellement utile qu'il
avait repris de la position mais j'ai
pas compris laquelle donc donc il l'a
dit mais j'attends de voir visiblement
c'est sur le fait parce que je disais vu
le montant des dépenses parce que c'est
vrai qu'on est habitué en France à
constater à déficit de 150 milliards
d'euros comme si c'était normal c'est
presque la moitié des dépenses couverts
par les recettes et un déficit bon je
lui ai dit il faudrait peut-être suivre
mieux les dépenses et la qualité de la
dépense il y a bah oui on va retenir
compte certes donc je suis content qu'il
prenne en compte ce bon sens mais on
peut pas dire que ce soit une
proposition concrète sur comment vous
qualifiez-vous ce budget le gouvernement
dit c'est un budget de protection pour
vous c'est quoi non c'est un budget
ordinaire comme si on n'était pas en
crise et protection quand les factures
de gaz et d'électricité augmente de 15%
pour payer des surprofis moi je
considère pas que ce soit de la
protection la ristourne sur le carburant
est abandonné au 1er janvier 2023 faut
le savoir faut que les gens aujourd'hui
il y a une baisse du carburant parce
qu'il y a une grosse ristourne croisée
entre total et le gouvernement mais ça
veut dire qu'au 1er janvier 2023 il se
passe quoi le gouvernement nous a dit en
commission que même si les prix flambés
à nouveau ils ne protégeraient seulement
ce qui travaille mais les retraités les
les hommes de leur famille les hommes ou
les femmes qui s'occupent des dents qui
sont des aidants comment ils vont faire
dans la ruralité moi je suis élu vous
l'avez dit de la somme tout le monde a
besoin de sa voiture pas seulement ceux
qui travaillent vous parlez des super
profils ce qui pourrait y avoir un
amendement commun entre la nuque et vous
pour faire passer un texte sur les super
profits mais moi je souhaite qu'on
puisse travailler avec toutes les forces
politiques qu'on a un objectif commun
c'est là la démarche de la gauche ils
veulent un rythme alors bon vous allez
signer ça j'ai dit j'ai pas de problème
si vous voulez le texte qu'ils ont
présenté reprend mon amendement de
juillet sur
jeudi seulement que le rythme n'est pas
approprié pour moi pour la fiscalité
parce que vous connaissez les délais
faut déjà que les députés signe après
faut que ça passe au Parlement après
faut que ça passe au Conseil
constitutionnel faut 9 mois pour avoir
les signatures après il faut que ça
repasse encore au Parlement et après
faut organiser le référendum donc là on
a au moins sur un an et demi deux ans or
vous savez qu'en loi fiscale on court
après le temps chaque année fiscal qui
passe c'est très compliqué de revenir
sur la taxation la proposition de la
nuque c'est-à-dire le tombeau si on me
demande de le signer je le signerai mais
je dirais enseignant attention ce n'est
pas le bon outil institutionnel ce qui
utile c'est l'amendement voir une
proposition de loi dans une niche
parlementaire qui sera plus rapide parce
que si c'est pour taxer les en 2024 les
surprofits 2022 le Conseil
constitutionnel à la fin dira à écouter
vous êtes lentilles mais on peut pas
taxer une entreprise deux ans après il y
a un autre point dans ce budget c'est
l'augmentation du nombre de postes de
fonctionnaires près de 11000 postes de
fonctionnaires en plus est-ce que ça
vous allez le soutenir visiblement oui
parce que ce sont dans des dans des
secteurs pardon importants l'éducation
la gestion la police qui sont des
demandes et des propositions de Marine
Le Pen donc nous voilà pour reprendre
votre question on n'est pas dans
l'opposition stérile mais
après il faut aussi que ces postes
soient bien utilisés et à quelle mission
voilà donc nous on s'interdit pas de
soutenir certains efforts budgétaires
mais après la politique que ces
fonctionnaires vont devoir appliquer
continu pour nous d'être de ne pas être
pertinente autre sujet de crispation le
CVAE est-ce que ça va être un sujet pour
vous quel est votre position là dessus
les impôts de production alors Marine Le
Pen avait proposé plutôt de supprimer la
cotisation foncière des entreprises qui
concernait plus les TPE artisans
commerçants pour nous qui pour nous
mettre plus d'être soutenu parce que bon
on votera sans doute la baisse de la
CVAE mais faut aussi reconnaître que
c'est on enlève une prime aux
collectivités qui développe l'économie
puisque par définition une cotisation
sur la valeur ajoutée ça ça pardon sa
fiscalise les entreprises qui créent de
la valeur sur le territoire donc c'est
toutes les collectivités qu'on fait des
efforts pour créer des zones d'activités
pour attirer des entreprises vont être
pénalisées alors que la CFE bon bah ça
concerne les entreprises qui sont
toujours là les artisans commerçants
donc je trouve que choisir la CVAE n'est
pas pertinent et une fois de plus c'est
plutôt une aide aux grandes entreprises
plutôt que petit
ce soir ministre membre de sa majorité
les présidents des trois groupes de sa
majorité Elisabeth bandit une réponse
sur la méthode en fin de semaine quelle
doit être la bonne méthode pour vous la
bonne méthode nous on est opposé à la
réforme des retraites mais à partir du
moment le président a gagné les
élections la bonne méthode c'est une loi
ordinaire ou un projet un vrai projet de
pelle FS modificatif qui permet
c'est un budget de la Sécurité sociale
rectificatif au début de l'année
Macron a gagné les élections c'est le
choix des Français il est en minorité
relative au Parlement il a le droit de
déposer un texte ce texte sera débattu
avec les partenaires sociaux dans le
respect de tous il passera devant le
conseil des détails il y aura une étude
d'impact nous on s'opposera à ce texte
mais ce sera dans une dans un cadre
normal si vous les mettez-vous aussi
quand même dans une démocratie
républicaine le fait que les oppositions
et connaissances d'un texte aussi
important et les partenaires sociaux un
texte aussi important quelques semaines
avant et que même le gouvernement j'ai
débattu avec Monsieur Yester sur votre
chaîne il y a quelques jours
était incapable de nous dire ce qui ce
qu'il en était comment voulez-vous qu'il
y a un débat normal c'est évidemment une
forme inacceptable de débat démocratique
on peut pas faire une réforme qui
concerne des millions de Français qui a
une ample qui qui concerne des milliards
d'euros qui visiblement en plus ces
milliards d'euros seront utilisés non
pas seulement pour les retraites mais
pour financer d'autres politiques par un
amendement au déboutés au détour d'un
texte alors le gouvernement semble dire
que
l'utilisation du 49-3 semble à peu près
inévitable 49-3 veut dire motion de
censure est-ce que vous pourriez vous
mettre d'accord sur un texte comment
entre la nuque et vous un texte
éventuellement qui pourrait être rédigé
par la nuque même Marine Le Pen l'a dit
nous on n'hésitera pas à censurer le
gouvernement si ce comporte ainsi y
compris avec les insoumis ah bah
absolument mais moi j'ai compris sur un
texte rédigé par les insoumis si vous
voulez c'est de la politique fiction je
pense pas qu'il y aura un texte commun
nous on n'a pas spécialement envie de
faire un texte commun avec la nupaisse
et eux n'ont plus je pense mais après
nous on n'a pas de de plus dur de
gazelle pour reprendre une expression de
de Monsieur Mélenchon il y a quelques
années quand il avait encore des propos
sensés à
devenir un texte qui n'est pas le nôtre
si l'objectif est le même vous savez moi
moi j'ai été oui les députés du
rassemblement national ils ont été élus
pour des objectifs politiques les
Français ils veulent pas savoir les
alliances les machins ils veulent savoir
est-ce que mon salaire va augmenter
est-ce que les surprofis vont être taxés
est-ce que la police doit avoir les
moyens est-ce que un gouvernement qui
est ce comporte mal et censuré
l'objectif politique c'est que ce
gouvernement soit censuré donc tous les
moyens évidemment dans le respect de la
République qui sont bons pour censurer
un gouvernement sont bons à prendre vous
savez les Français n'iront pas la
virgule et le texte de la nupesse ils
veulent savoir si oui ou non le texte le
gouvernement est censuré il y a un texte
aussi qui va nous intéresser on imagine
c'est le texte sur le développement des
énergies renouvelables qui les a
accéléré se développements puisque la
somme votre département est-ce que il y
a le plus éoliennes terrestre est-ce que
ça c'est un texte que vous allez
soutenir ce test je ne l'ai pas vu donc
moi je j'ai pas d'opposition à tout il
est hors de question qu'on soutienne le
développement de des éoliennes
terrestres et nos mères aussi d'ailleurs
donc la somme elle record de production
et on le voit bien les énergies
intermittentes parce qu'on dit
renouvelables mais par exemple on est
favorable au développement du petit
hydraulique on est favorable au gaz vert
dans la Somme on aurait pu faire des
biocarburants avec la betterave depuis
des années on est favorable à
l'hydrogène à Marine Le Pen a-t-elle la
personne première personnalité politique
à proposer une filière hydrogène en 2005
donc c'est pas une opposition entre le
renouvelable et le non renouvelable
c'est d'opposition entre les bons
renouvelables que je vous ai cités et
les éoliennes terrestres on voit bien
aujourd'hui avoir des éoliennes
terrestres comme le fonctionne pas
notamment quand il fait très chaud ou
très froid on a besoin de gaz ou pire de
charbon donc le gouvernement je vous
rappelle que pendant la présidentielle
Emmanuel Macron avait osé envoyer un SMS
à tous les Français pour leur dire
Marine Le Pen va attention Marine Le Pen
va réouvrir les centrales à charbon en
France c'est lui qui a ouvert les
centrales à charbon puisqu'il a mis le
premier producteur d'électricité de qui
était la France en situation de
dépendance de l'Allemagne donc les
éoliennes ne sont pas une énergie fiable
parallèlement Emmanuel Macron devrait
annoncé la construction de nouveaux
réacteurs nu faire ça va dans le bon
sens ça selon vous oui ça ça va dans le
bon sens on le demande depuis très
longtemps il ne veut pas en lancer assez
nous on veut deux tranches de 10
réacteurs sur 20 ans qui nous paraît
correspondent en fait au renouvellement
du parc mais aussi au fait qu'il faut
produire de plus en plus d'électricité
parce que c'est on parle souvent
d'écologie dans l'écologie il y a la
façon dont on produit l'électricité mais
il y a aussi ramener l'industrie en
France parce que vous savez que 50% de
la pollution de la France est liée aux
importations et le rassemblement
national et le seul parti politique qui
propose une politique pour
réindustrialiser parce que si vous avez
des hommes politiques qui viennent vous
dire oui oui on va ramener les usines
mais il y a pas d'électricité pour faire
fonctionner les usines c'est des hommes
politiques qui vous mentent donc on est
nous il faut encore plus d'électricité
que ce que dit plus de centrales
nucléaires qui va occuper l'Assemblée
nationale en début d'année prochaine
Gérald Darmanin a promis un texte de loi
sur l'immigration est-ce que c'est une
bonne chose vous l'attendiez ce texte ou
pas oui je pense que tous les Français
attend une un texte qui permet de mieux
contrôler l'immigration mais je pense
qu'il n'attendent rien de Monsieur
Darmanin sur ce domaine là donc on va
voir Emmanuel Macron a lancé une piste
qui est de répartir les étrangers dans
les zones
les Français n'ont pas envie de vivre
l'enfer que vivent les métropoles dans
tout le territoire donc la solution de
l'immigrations
si vous voulez les métropoles il y a un
certain nombre de dirigeants politiques
de métropoles qui soutiennent la
submersion migratoire qui a pris
constate que leur territoire ne peut
plus gérer ses pauvres gens qui arrivent
à qui on promet tout et n'importe quoi
et qui sont dans la précarité et ils
veulent les répartir partout en France
les Français veulent qu'on renvoie en
particulier clandestins je vous rappelle
qu'il y a entre 300 000 et 500 000
clandestins notamment en Île-de-France
ces personnes ne va pas être réparties
sur le territoire elles sont en
clandestinité elles doivent repartir et
les personnes qui demandent le droit
d'asile et qui n'ont pas le droit
d'asile doivent repartir bon mais sur
les personnes en situation régulière
aujourd'hui c'est pas elle qui pose un
problème d'accueil aujourd'hui le
problème le principal d'accueil c'est
d'une part les clandestins qui par
définition ne sait pas comment les gérer
et surtout les personnes qui ont demandé
le droit d'asile et qui ne sont très
très peu renvoyés voilà et de toute
façon là vous avez raison c'est qu'il
faut en fin de grande un grand débat sur
l'immigration en France c'est la seule
grande politique qui n'a jamais où les
Français n'ont jamais été consultés
voient on voit bien dans les sondages
peut-être pas lieu visiblement donc
est-ce qu'on peut se passer de ce grand
débat et discuter du projet de loi
uniquement ah bah le yoral projet de loi
mais nous même peut-être qu'on lancera
vous savez Marine Le Pen a proposé un
référendum sur l'immigration peut-être
que la nuesse à proposer un référendum
d'initiative partagé sur la fiscalité
qui me paraît pas le bon le bon outil
par contre ça me paraît être un bon
outil pour l'immigration
oui autre proposition est maintenant de
votre groupe une commission d'enquête
parlementaire pour lutter contre les
ingérences étrangères est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire plus oui parce que
en fait au début on a on n'a pas cru que
les mensonges enfin les énormités de la
macronie sur le ingérences russes
puisqu'on est en fait vous avez un
certain nombre de
dirigeants de la majorité j'ai vu que
monsieur séjourné la revait un tour de
scène faites font des insinuations
permanence des accusations mais jamais
précises parce que sinon c'est de la
diffamation donc nous ils disent oui on
va faire une commission d'enquête pour
prouver que le rassemblement national
est très méchant moi si vous voulez je
n'accuse pas je le pardon je n'accepte
pas qu'on remette en cause mon intégrité
patriotique et l'intégrité patriotique
de tous mes collègues commissions
et qu'on prouve que le rassemble
national n'a absolument aucun lien avec
la Russie et n'est absolument pas il y a
la question
c'est pour contrer l'ensemble vous savez
mais vous savez les hommes politiques
enfin vous savez les hommes et les
femmes politiques on est quand même
engagé par du pays moi quand on remet en
cause mon patriotisme et moi ça me
franchement ça non seulement ça me
bouleverse mais ça m'indique moi je me
suis engagé je veux dire nul n'est
parfait je ne suis pas un saint mais le
remettre en cause mon patriotisme et mes
convictions en disant je suis un agent
russe Monsieur le Maire a quand même dit
en commission le jour que je soutenais
la violence c'est-à-dire les crimes de
l'armée russe voilà donc ils sont dans
un délire ce qui vous a fait réagir les
commissions
qui par exemple dans cette commission à
comprendre mais je sais plus sur quelle
chaîne vous avez un ambassadeur un
ancien ambassadeur en Russie qui le jour
a fait des insinuations disant oui il y
a des gens qui venaient aussi et qui
repartaient avec des valises et bien que
ce monsieur viennent sous serment dire
de qui parle il parce qu'il y a pas vos
collègues ont fait leur travail les
journalistes sont dit mais de qui vous
parlez et là hop patatra le
l'ambassadeur n'a pas voulu donner le
nom donc soit on donne des noms et les
personnes qui sont responsables de ça
doivent être sévèrement condamnés parce
qu'il s'agit pas de faire du Commentaire
la commission d'enquête parlementaire
s'il y a des responsables d'ingérence
russe mais d'ingérence aussi
qatari d'ingérence algérienne
d'ingérence chinoise d'ingérence
américaine ils doivent être sévèrement
condamnés le fait que des hommes
politiques de quelques parties qu'ils
soient puisse être soumis à une
assurance étrangère et très grave
enquête ne concernerait que le
rassemblement national ou d'autres
parties à partir du moment c'est une
commission d'enquête parlementaire
d'ailleurs je remarque depuis qu'on l'a
déposé ah bah tout le monde a disparu il
y a aucune force politique qui veut
soutenir cette commission par nous donc
visiblement c'est pas le rassemblement
national qui a quelque chose sur les
ingérences étrangères concernant tout
politique évidemment un dernier mot sur
un match de foot qui fait beaucoup
parler c'est un match de foot qui doit
avoir lieu ce soir entre l'équipe de
France de foot de l'Assemblée nationale
et des anciens joueurs internationaux
profit d'une association pour la
première fois il y a des députés du
rassemblement national dans l'équipe de
France de l'assemblée et la France
insoumise le PS Europe Écologie Les
Verts boycott le match car il refuse
cette banalisation de l'extrême droite
c'est ce qu'ils disent la présidente du
groupe Renaissance aurbergé recommande à
ses députés de ne pas y participer
comment réagissez-vous bon c'est
franchement on est passé du tragique de
des affaires de violences sexuelles au
comique c'est absolument ridicule je
pense que c'est une diversion de la
France insoumise un pour essayer de
changer de sujet voilà parce que c'est
tellement ridicule que je ne vois pas
d'autre explication à ce à cette espèce
de crise d'adolescence
de Monsieur Bayou et compagnie bon la
réalité c'est quoi c'est que Monsieur
Aliot quand il était député a joué avec
Monsieur Coquerel au rugby et que
Monsieur Macron avait envoyé une lettre
pour féliciter Monsieur Louis Aliot de
leur médaille je crois face au
Britannique donc en fait on est dans une
dans une mascarade et puis c'est
ridicule et en plus c'est contraire aux
valeurs sportives si vous voulez moi je
veux bien dans ce cas là ils vont quoi
qu'on partage une pièce à l'Assemblée
ils vont arrêter de respirer bon donc
c'est ridicule on est tous là pour
servir les Français il y avait un
maskite en plus c'est un masque
caritatif pour une bonne cause je trouve
ça déplorable et je pense que les
Français seront atterrés de par cette
solution moi je joue pas au foot mais je
veux bien faire d'autres sports
merci Jean-Philippe Tanguy merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous regarder
de la dépêche crystal cérus qui fuit
Poutine c'est à la Une merci au club des
territoires
[Musique]